la recta tangente a la gráfica de la
función f en el punto 23 pasa a través
del punto 76 encuentra f prima de 2
siempre que te encuentres con algo por
el estilo la verdad es que ayuda
bastante visualizarlo puedes dibujar lo
en algún lugar o puedes simplemente
visualizarlo en tu cabeza pero como por
el momento tú no puedes saber qué es lo
que pasa adentro de mi cabeza vamos a
dibujarlo si es que por aquí estoy
dibujando la información que nos dan en
este ejercicio este es el eje x este es
el eje y y los puntos relevantes en este
ejercicio son 23 y 76 así es que en el
eje de las x vamos a poner 12
4 5 6 7 y en el eje de leyes vamos a
poner 1 2 3 4 5 y 6
tenemos aquí al punto 2 3 el punto 2,3
gay este es el punto 2 3 y también
tenemos al punto 7 6 que se encuentra en
el 7,6 aquí está el punto 76 y ahora
recordemos qué es lo que nos dice este
ejercicio nos dice que la recta tangente
a efe en este punto pasa por el punto 76
pero a ver si es la recta tangente df en
el punto 23 entonces esa recta también
tiene que pasar por el punto 23 de hecho
es el único punto en el que sabemos que
la tangente
efe
y se intersectan así es que la tangente
pasa por el punto 23 y nos están
diciendo que pasa por el punto 76 y para
definir una recta sólo necesitamos dos
puntos entonces sabemos que la recta
tangente se ve más o menos así bueno no
me quedo tan bien se ve más o menos así
bueno ahora sí salió suficientemente
bien esta recta es tangente a la función
f en el punto 23 y sabemos que pasa por
el punto 76 no sabemos nada más de efe
pero podríamos imaginarnos cómo se ve la
función f podría verse así lo único que
necesitamos es que sea tangente a la
recta en el punto 23 así es que cuando
nos dicen encuentra f prima de 2 lo que
realmente nos están pidiendo aquí es que
encontremos la pendiente de la tangente
a efe
x2 y bueno si x es igual a 2 la recta
tangente a la gráfica de f es esta recta
que tenemos aquí en este ejercicio nos
dieron dos puntos que pasan por la recta
tangente a efe cuando x es igual a 2 así
es que simplemente tenemos que encontrar
la pendiente de esta recta porque está
pendiente va a ser la tasa de cambio de
la función f
en este punto es la derivada de f en 2
la pendiente de la recta tangente porque
ésta es la recta tangente a efe así es
que encontremos está pendiente ahora
como sabemos la pendiente es el cambio
en el eje de leyes entre el cambio en el
eje de las x así es que si estamos yendo
de 23 a 76 el cambio en x es igual a ver
estamos pasando de x igualados a x 7
entonces el cambio en x
5 y también necesitamos el cambio en
jeff el cambio
es igual bueno pues estamos yendo de
6 así es que el cambio es igual a 3 y la
tasa de cambio o sea el cambio entre el
cambio en x es igual a 3 entre 5 así es
que la pendiente de esta recta es tres
quintos lo cual nos dice que la
pendiente de la recta tangente a efe en
2 es tres quintos y eso también es la
derivada de f en dos porque esta es la
recta tangente a efe en dos bueno ahora
vamos a hacer otro ejercicio para una
función g sabemos que g de menos uno es
igual a tres y que g prima de menos uno
es igual a menos dos cuál es la ecuación
de la recta tangente a la gráfica de g
cuando x es igual a menos uno bueno
nuevamente me parece que es una muy
buena idea visualizar todo
ejercicio entonces ponemos por aquí el
eje de la siesta el eje del h
y el eje de las x eje de las x veamos
sabemos qué g de menos 1 es igual a 3
entonces el punto menos 13 está en
nuestra función tenemos por aquí menos 1
y 1 2 y 3 este punto pertenece a la
gráfica de g el punto menos 13 está en
nuestra función g ahora por otro lado
también sabemos que g prima de menos 1
es menos 2 y esto lo que nos dice es que
la pendiente de la recta tangente a la
función g en este punto es menos 2 la
derivada de g en menos 1 es menos 2 la
pendiente de la recta tangente a g
cuando x es igual a menos 1 es menos 2
así es que vamos a usar esta información
para dibujar la recta tangente
como tiene una pendiente de menos 2 se
ve más o menos así si nos movemos en el
eje de las x en sentido positivo si
tenemos un cambio en x de 1 entonces
bajamos 2 en el eje de leyes en el
sentido negativo y eso es lo que
significa que esta recta tenga una
pendiente menos 2 bueno y ahorita
podríamos preguntarnos oye y la función
g como se ve
pues la función g podría verse así lo
importante es que la función g pasa por
el punto menos 13 y la pendiente de su
recta tangente es menos 2 y después la
función g podríamos imaginarnos que hace
cualquier cosa pero lo único que nos
importa en este ejercicio es cuál es la
ecuación de la recta tangente y bueno
hay muchas formas en las que podemos
hacer esto porque hay muchas formas de
describir a una recta pero podemos
escoger una por ejemplo podemos utilizar
la forma que nos dice que ya es igual a
m por x + b donde m es la pendiente y b
es la intersección con el eje del h
ahora la pendiente ya sabemos
exactamente cuánto es la pendiente es
menos 2 entonces podemos decir que allí
es igual a menos 2
por x + b y así ya nada más nos falta
encontrar be pero nosotros sabemos que
el punto menos 13 está en esta recta
tangente y aquí vamos a utilizar algo
que viste probablemente en álgebra uno
hace algún tiempo pero aquí en esta
ecuación para encontrar a b vamos a
sustituir las coordenadas y x de este
punto que pertenece a esta línea así es
que cuando ya es igual a 3 está 3
tenemos que menos 2 por x que en este
caso x es menos uno más b y ahora vamos
a resolver esto menos 2 x menos 1 es 2 y
entonces si restamos 2 de los dos lados
nos queda que uno es igual a b y listo
ya terminamos
es la ecuación de esta línea de la recta
tangente a g cuando x es igual a menos 1
que es igual a menos 2 x más 1 y bueno
por supuesto que hay otras formas para
resolver este ejercicio por ejemplo
pudimos haber escrito la ecuación de la
línea en forma de punto pendiente o en
su forma estándar o como lo hicimos pero
por lo menos esta vez así es como lo
proceso mi cerebro